Speaker 1: Well, the next layer in the American
laughing stock of Republicans controlling the
House of Representatives is happening
now. Not only are Republicans blocking
Democrats Adam Schiff and Eric Swalwell from
the House Intelligence panel, they have placed
Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Trump's lunatic Dr.
Ronny Jackson on the coronavirus committee.
I know, I know. It is an absolute pathetic
joke now on the bonus show later today.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where
you want to make money? Yeah. Everybody
else who makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Exactly. We are going to talk about the
first part of what I just told you. Kevin McCarthy
blocking Adam Schiff and Eric Swalwell from the
House intel panel. NBC news reports Speaker Kevin
McCarthy followed through on his threat to prevent
the two Democratic lawmakers from keeping their
seats on the Intelligence Committee. So that's
happening. Let me mention a different aspect
to this, which is closer to the bottom of this
article. Meanwhile, McCarthy named Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor GREENE, who had been suspended
from social media platforms for promoting
COVID disinformation to the select panel on the
coronavirus pandemic. Congressman Ronny Jackson
of Texas, a Republican who was Trump's White House
physician, also got the nod for the COVID panel.
Jeffries will now have an opportunity to appoint
Democratic members to the special panels. They
also, by the way, before we start weighing in
further on this, there's also a weaponization
panel. What are they studying themselves now?
Republicans have said the new weaponization panel
will examine Republican accusations that the
Justice Department, FBI and other law enforcement
are being weaponized to investigate conservatives,
including Trump. They're going to look at the
FBI search of Mar-A-Lago and other things. Okay.
Listen, we knew they were going to do this. We
knew that they were going to flip everything on
its head up, was going to be down left was going
to be right. They were going to investigate Hunter
Biden rather than anybody actually connected to
government today. We knew that they were going
to do all of these different things. And look at
the reactions from these folks. Ronnie Jackson,
this is maybe one of the most dishonest, prominent
doctors. I mean, I can think of some others,
actually. But Ronnie Jackson is the guy who, as
Trump's doctor said, Trump was six feet three
inches tall and weighed £239. Listen, I'm not
about fat shaming. I'm not about whatever. I'm
against lying. And there is no way in hell. Trump
is six three and weighs 239. But Ronnie Jackson
kept up the lie. Ronnie Jackson tweeting and
gleefully responding to this committee assignment,
saying, quote, I'm proud to announce that I've
been chosen for this Select Subcommittee on the
coronavirus pandemic. Every lie told to us
by Fauci will be revealed. Every lie about
the vaccine will be revealed. Every lie that
was used to lock you down will be unearthed.
We will reveal the truth. By the way, does anybody
remember being locked down? I remember when I had
to get takeout for a couple of weeks and then sit
outside at restaurants. But I have to tell you,
I don't remember any lockdowns. Ronnie
Jackson going on in a separate tweet to say,
be ready. FAUCI The American people are about to
find out everything you did to this country during
COVID. I think Dr. Fauci would be glad for the
country to learn about all of the things he did
during COVID. Marjorie Taylor GREENE tweeting, I
am honored to serve on the Select Subcommittee on
the Coronavirus pandemic. It's time to reveal the
truth on the origins of COVID. Wow. I didn't know
she knew anything about that. The authoritarian
Democrat response vaccines and Fauci's NIAID
involvement in gain of function research. We
are a joke, folks. We are a joke. The world
sees this and wonders what the hell is wrong with
these people? Remember this moment where Marjorie
Taylor GREENE was asked by a reporter about how
children died of COVID? People who weren't obese
died of COVID and Marjorie Taylor GREENE laughed.
Speaker 3: It's dangerous. Do you feel any
responsibility for keeping people in Georgia safe?
You know, there are children, skinny people who
have died of the coronavirus. Do you feel any
responsibility to protect me? You know what? I
think people's responsibility is their own. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So she now will be examining and
investigating. What happened during the
coronavirus pandemic. It is absolutely
bonkers. And, you know, this is going to be
endless grandstanding now. One thing I want to
ask you about is. When they have these covered
hearings. Right. It's something we could cover
live. But would my coverage of it legitimize or
legitimate to use a less common version of the
term? Would my coverage, in a sense legitimize
hearings that are completely unserious in every
way? The entertainment value might be high, but
these really are people who should be relegated
to irrelevant jobs, not anything serious. So
is it the type of thing that we should cover,
live or not? Let me know. Leave a comment
and I'm curious to know your thoughts.